-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
You're gathered with the family.
I want to wish everyone a very
happy Thanksgiving right now.
Happy Thanksgiving, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Round of applause -- how many
of you are asleep right now?
Well, you're going to want
to wake up for this,
because we have an amazing show.
The one-and-only Cher
is my guest tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Earlier today, Cher headlined
the Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was --
That actually wasn't planned.
Whenever she drives down
the street,
a parade forms around her.
That's just what happens.
That's right --
today was the 97th
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade.
It was really fun.
Although, at one point,
there was a large gust of wind,
and the SpongeBob balloon
got its nipple pierced
by the Chrysler Building.
It's really interesting.
I hope you all had
a great Thanksgiving.
Once again,
I overdid it on the food.
After dinner, I dropped
an Alka-Seltzer into some Pepto
into some Gas-x and called it
a medical turducken.
I love how after dinner, we're
like, "I won't eat for a week,"
and then, three hours later,
we're standing over the sink,
gnawing on a cold drumstick.
My family actually doesn't have
turkey on Thanksgiving.
Because of my relationship
with NBC,
we're only allowed
to eat peacock.
Yeah.
Actually, it was
a great Thanksgiving,
but it's almost midnight now,
and on behalf of everyone
at home watching,
there's something
I need to say.
♪♪
Guests, get out.
I'm serious.
Button up your pants and leave.
I'm talking to you, Pamela.
You're not "family."
Go digest in your own home.
Meredith, stop offering
to do the dishes,
because now everyone
has to pretend
that they were going to
clean the kitchen tonight,
which they
definitely were not.
By the way, Brian,
we all noticed
that noise your body
made 10 minutes ago.
That was scary. Get some help.
Meredith, I wasn't joking.
Out. Now.
Well, I guess if you're staying,
I just learned to play
"Wonderwall" on the guitar.
Oh, now you're leaving?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Turkey gobbling ]
Well, I saw that
President Biden and his family
spent Thanksgiving in Nantucket.
Yeah, Biden made sure
an authentic Thanksgiving meal
was served, and he would know
because he was there
for the first one.
Meanwhile,
former president Trump
also celebrated Thanksgiving.
Yep. It's a little different
at the Trumps' house.
When they cook the turkey,
it's over three days
in a tanning bed.
Ron DeSantis
had a good Thanksgiving,
although things got
a little tense
when he yelled,
"For the last time,
why am I seated
at the kids' table?"
Finally, guys, what is
Thanksgiving without football?
You know...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Earlier tonight,
the Seattle Seahawks
faced off against
the San Francisco 49ers.
Now, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards,
like Most Valuable Player.
But they also give out awards
during the season, too.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
-♪ "Tonight Show Superlatives" ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Our first player
is from the 49ers.
It's George Kittle.
He was voted...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kind of old.
Next up, from the Seahawks,
is DeeJay Dallas.
[ Laughter ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter, applause ]
Next up, from the 49ers,
is Corey Luciano.
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
Next up, from the Seahawks,
is Michael Jackson.
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
-Beat it.
-Next up, from the Seahawks,
is Levi Bell.
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
Next up, from the Seahawks,
is Colby Parkinson.
He was voted...
[ Applause ]
"Welcome."
Next, from the Seahawks,
is Jon Rhattigan.
He was voted...
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next, from the 49ers,
is Jon Feliciano.
He was voted...
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
Next up, from the 49ers,
is Jake Tonges.
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
"I'm mad."
[ Applause ]
Finally, from the Seahawks,
is Will Dissly.
He was voted...
There you have it.
Those are your superlatives.
We have a great show.
Happy Thanksgiving!
Give it up for The Roots
right there!
-♪ Holding on for
one more turkey sandwich ♪
♪ Holding on for
♪ For the turkey sandwich ♪
-Happy Thanksgiving!
What a show
we have for you tonight.
She is one of the most iconic
superstars on the planet
and one of the best-selling
music artists of all time,
with over 100 million
records sold.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her new album, "Christmas,"
is out now.
Cher is here,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be talking to her,
and then, later in the show,
we'll be revealing
some shocking secrets.
-Ooh! Shocking!
-You don't want to miss that.
Plus, his new comedy special,
"The Old Man and the Pool,"
is streaming now on Netflix.
The very funny Mike Birbiglia
is joining us tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love Mike.
-"Old Man and the Pool."
And we got great music.
Offset is performing tonight.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And here she is.
-Oh, my gosh. It's Cher.
-Cher, I didn't know...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I didn't know you were
back there the whole time.
"I was just taking a nap."
-Oh, my gosh!
-You were taking a --
Now, you surprised me, yeah.
"I'm so happy
to be here on the show."
Do you like our set?
Do you like the...
"I'm a big fan of The Roots,
but I love this audience."
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"New York City!
New York City is the
best audience in the world."
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
-What's that?
Oh, really?
-She's got a secret.
-Oh! Say it again.
Do you want to say it
a little bit louder?
"I want to crowd-surf."
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think it's dangerous.
I think it's too dangerous!
There's no way, Cher!
It's dangerous.
Don't do that.
"I don't care."
What are you talking about?
What are you...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Be careful, Cher!
Be careful!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're a dear.
Cher, that was very dangerous of
you, but very, very cool.
"Alright, I'm just gonna
take a nap.
I'm gonna just take
a nap back here,
and I'll be back out
when my segment starts."
Alright, Cher,
ladies and gentlemen.
That's Cher's.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She wanted to crowd-surf.
Guys, I hope everyone
had a great Thanksgiving.
You know,
today is just about over,
and I already had dinner,
so I thought I'd take a look
at my Thanksgiving bingo card,
if I could.
-Oh, great.
-Yeah, I just want
to take a look at it now.
Let's see how I did.
Alright, let's see.
First up here, we have...
Nope. Didn't happen this year.
-Not this year.
-Not this year. Fortunately.
-Yeah.
-This next square says...
Yeah, I did get that one.
-Got that one.
"Input?"
-Let's see the next square.
I got that one, too.
Let's look at
this next one here.
Yeah.
Whoa!
Next, here's the free space
here. This says...
Everyone gets the free space.
-I got to watch that game, yeah.
-Next square says...
Is this rizz?
-You're like 30, right?
-Is this rizz?
[ Audience cheering ]
-Oh, no, Cher's gonna dab.
♪♪
[ Audience cheering ]
-[ Laughs ]
Up next, there's...
"I think it's
an exclamation point.
There's an exclamation point
instead of the 'L.'"
Alright. Oh, the next one
here says...
Gross. I know what I look like.
-Don't post that.
-And, finally...
Oh, yeah, anyway...
It's another great Thanksgiving.
[ Applause ]
Guys, today is a day
that is all about giving thanks,
so I thought,
what better day to write up
my weekly thank-you notes?
Do you guys mind?
Is that okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, can I get some
thank-you-note-writing
music, please?
[ Gentle melody playing ]
-Thank you,
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade,
for being the worst time
for the edibles to kick in.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Slo-mo ] SpongeBob.
[ Gentle melody playing ]
-Thank you,
Thanksgiving leftovers,
for also being a sly way
to steal someone's Tupperware.
Yeah.
"I'll return it."
[ Chuckles ]
[ Gentle melody playing ]
Thank you,
electric carving knife,
for making it sound like
my turkey has a
"personal massager."
-[ Imitates buzzing ]
Ew! Ew! Wow!
I just got that one.
-I'm not sure if I did.
-Oh, my God.
[ Gentle melody playing ]
-Thank you, playing
a board game with family
after Thanksgiving dinner,
for being a fun way to say,
"I don't think
we've fought enough yet."
[ Gentle melody playing ]
Thank you,
inflatable yard decorations,
for letting my neighbors
celebrate the holidays
with a 24/7 leaf blower.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank-you notes!